(gentle upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Cannabis, it's
the most frequently used
illicit substance in the United States
and arguably, one of
the most controversial.
Cannabis, or marijuana, is a drug
derived from certain strains
of the plant cannabis sativa.
The plant's flowers and leaves
contain chemical compounds
called cannabinoids,
which produce cannabis's
mind altering effects.
This high is largely
caused by the cannabinoid
called tetrahydrocannabinol, or THC.
When THC from cannabis
is ingested or inhaled,
it overwhelms the body's
natural levels of THC
in the cardiovascular and
central nervous systems.
In the brain, THC attaches to neurons
that send information via chemicals
known as neurotransmitters.
The THC decreases the
amount of neurotransmitters
the neurons produce, thereby decreasing
the amount of information transmitted.
This results in psychoactive effects
such as lack of coordination, memory loss,
hallucinations, and increased appetite.
Because of some of the
psychoactive effects,
cannabis had been used
for medicinal purposes
for thousands of years.
Then around the 20th Century,
cannabis became more accessible
and more widely used for
recreational purposes.
But by the late 1960s, the use
and possession of cannabis
became illegal in many countries
due to debate surrounding
the drug's effects.
Opponents state that
the dangers of cannabis
include inducing heart attacks,
decreasing sperm count,
and stunting brain development,
particularly in teenagers.
Proponents, especially
of medicinal marijuana,
site benefits including treating seizures,
relieving chronic pain,
and preventing nausea
induced by chemotherapy.
Because of cannabis's costs and benefits,
many countries continue to wrestle
with how to best approach and regulate
the controversial substance.